[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
porter un gilet volet acquis le 8 me
souviens qu'il ya quelque chose j'aime
bien cette série alors l'indiquent de la
rédac du gros dossier ce soir et je
pense qu'on va y avoir beaucoup de
problèmes alors c'est quand vous voulez
vous c'est que vous êtes mon patron
cyril c'est que je vous dois fidélité
maintenant levitt voix vous le savez
ça commence quand on commence par 50
comme chaque semaine et dans un instant
guillaume genton va prendre très cher 50
secondes insight cyril comme chaque
semaine tout ce qui se passe pendant les
play off pendant les magnétos avec cyril
regardez bien comment ils accueillent
les invités surtout les petits nouveaux
de ses news c'est vraiment du n'importe
quoi cette émission
salut les loups devenu dans sa catégorie
side depuis peu et on commence tout avec
baba qui a des projets pour ces
intervenants de très gros projets et
canal si
tu t'inquiètes pas
en tout cas matures et une qualité il
c'est accepter les compléments des
autres est bon alors sont marrantes est
beau c'est
toujours su que jean michel avait un
grand coeur il s'inquiète pour sa copine
isabelle
dans les bras
décidément c'est une obsession ba veut
absolument faire ken le petit loupé ses
news line de dire pas ici mais on
n'entend que les journalistes cheikh
kane mais
certainement terken
la terre battue de hambourg c'est
accueillir les petites nouvelles
c'est pas mal on touche et jamais comme
une panacée président est en voie d
anniversaire le truc tout ça
bien sûr
et vous l'ambiance est au beau fixe
entre gilles verdez et bernard montiel
bad alors franchement qu'il aille là bas
qu'ils resteraient
vrai ou faux grand mère
et en terme de jeu d'acteur de l'ormeau
n'a rien enlevé à dicaprio oui bon
j'étais plus les pour cette bonne base
de leurs mots s'il te plaît aux de leurs
mots tu arrives en retard tu manges les
bana tu fais chier tout le monde
n'est autre que ni le sport et la
finalité ça fait cinquante 7227 c'est
vrai que vous êtes sollicité par de très
très grands sportifs pour faire des
matches de paddle notamment le plus
iconique des joueurs français de
football oui oui oui zidane neymar
et oui c'est pas le sien anatomy sont
occupés à mon budget
et pas des masses
je pense surtout sans tuer bush et
c'est une fin de carrière pour jean
michel maire [ __ ] patois montjean mais
pas toi
deux projets
dommage
tomana combat
le sait on le dit souvent
regardez la séquence qui me suivent les
loups de l'enm au stade kieffer
et on termine avec baba qui finalement
nos projets pour journalistes de ces
news à bono pour moi je cherche un
patron de banque n'est pas la télé c'est
comme ça
certainement certaines carrément
oui si vous voulez le faire quel jeu
n'aviez pas une copine entachée si j'ai
une meuf en tête pour lui enfin qui a
fait la copine de kelly exactement magna
elle en a parlé dans gmail à gmail en
tête plm et pour lui en fait voilà je
voulais surtout que maya les en tête oui
mais ça maya vous inquiétez pas
on va y aller une grosse tête
mariano mayala qui fait bayala d'accord
c'est déjà fait j'ai déjà checker ses
bras inquiétez pas on est on est on est
sur le bon chemin par contre je demande
des excuses à isabelle oui ce que
j'appelle environnementalement s'il faut
un mois non c'est vrai je suis désolé je
je pensais pas c'est presque une
allemande finalement vous non je m'en
fout en fait
je suis désolé en fait
j'avais il avait l'excusé le danger par
mais franchement je tombe d'autant que
c'est faux donc je ne vais pas m'excuser
mais en plus c'est vrai que c'est pas
ton merci joe cocker ou
jacques au caire le super cougar au mot
monsieur je vais te faire kent en fait
vous le dit à l'antenne et les gens qui
nous regardent ils entendent ce que vous
dites
la télévision sur moi d'essayer pas de
venir
si j'avais prévu ça maintenant mais
comme vous voulez demander je vais le
faire tout de suite il ya un chroniqueur
qui envoie votre portefeuille cyril un
chroniqueur qui en veut à votre
patrimoine chroniqueurs qui en veut à
votre argent mais bon vous savez je ne
laisserai pas faire semblant le
chroniqueur s'est bien longtemps aux os
et aux journaux qui était censé être
versé soit si elle ne sait pas ce que je
vais voir oui on en a parlé on m'a dit
eh bien allez froid dans le dos on a vu
il ya un instant que guillaume j'entends
avait jeté son dévolu sur audry qu'il
avait jeté son dévolu sur fiona mais
figurez-vous que delphine est toujours
dans la partie et celui ci utilise les
pires stratagème pour la saison on voit
à wendel c'est le retour de 700 km de
thatta
le jeu de ça va partir en sucette sur la
tête de thatta
généralement pour ac se
décider
[Rires]
6-6 ça marche pas
c'est un gentil garçon
[Musique]
p 500
était superbe
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
une réaction
[Musique]
ça m'a blessée la whey voici super ça
c'est
trop d'émotions être défoncé sacha je
vais te le dire oui euh
je vais
un petit peu raccourci est accro dit
pourquoi ce que je suis extrêmement
blessé vous êtes blessée blessée parce
que je croyais que j'avais un ami cet
ami s'est et guillaume genton je vais
tout prêter c'est vrai
mon jacuzzi
et serviettes
mon peignoir de bain c'est vrai ma
chambre à
bout
s'il exclut
et yahoo jean thomas et trahissent
allemand
genton
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire attendez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très net je ne joue pas de violons
[Rires]
quel talent
[Musique]
ce n'est pas une question d'argent vous
savez que vous êtes mon frère m'avait
toujours dit que grâce à vous j'allais
pécho et pour pécho delphine j'ai besoin
vous me donniez 50% tout ce que vous
avez
[Musique]
écouté
on continue à jouer
et nous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si on peut il a utilisé le paddle il a
utilisé le paddle c'est une horreur ce
match aux airs horrible franchement non
mais j'ai vraiment envie de vous voir
jouer j'adore
c'est ce qui nous vaut quoi à nouveau
vrai signe pas pour moi je vous dis aux
demandes rien jamais rien ah non mais
vous je nomme je suis contente pas du
tout un creux voit quoi qu'est ce que
fait ce week-end ce week end puis un
tournoi de paddle et bunge tenure vous
regardez mémoire pour rien pas pour 50%
pour rien pour vous regardez c'est vrai
oui absolument c'est extrêmement plaisir
ces belles je viens quand demain voyais
absolument demain six mois demain 15
heures demain 15 heures bien sûr c'est
noté et on parlera des 50% non mais moi
à 32 suffi
pour faire ce que je fais c'est que ce
week-end pour de vrai 3% 3 % de ce que
vous avez je prends ma mission pour sa
vie de générations ça me va très bien
quitte à terre à côté de ces panneaux
meyers est annulé pour vous c'est annulé
pour vous demander à nouveau aux états
vous êtes un vil personnage
tout en normandie et je dîne avec le
petit casta non ce prix vous aller à
deauville oui ah bah je commencerai
peut-être ah c'est vrai non non
ils adressent merci qui veut venir en
aide avec moi amusez-vous rien du tout
non c'est vrai oui eh bien écoutez
je me tape les 200 km avec vos côtés
sur le pea sa côte est où
le ph oui écoutez d'où des regrettés
[Musique]
vous emmerdez pas franchement merci et
vous vous retirez vous